Let's seek the Lord together now for the beauty and purity that
He always has desired for us. Let's pray.
Father, I praise you.
You've been so patiently, continually
preparing us for this moment.
I praise you for the plan and the glory of your plan to bring about
holiness in our lives
for hundreds and even thousands of years before time
began or the earth was created.
I praise you that you draw us to holiness.
You planned for holiness in my life, in the life of my prayer
partner that's here praying with me today.
I pray, O God, that you would take us to that place.
Lord, we trust you. We rest ourselves in your hand.
Every difficulty and trial and tribulation, every
pain, every negative experience, every blessing,
everything has been leading up to us being holy like you planned
for us to be.
Praise you, Father. I praise you for your eternal plan.
I praise you for the glory and the beauty of your holiness, and that you have
always intended to make us like that.
So God, would you bring that holiness and that purity in
your sight, that blamelessness, would you bring it to pass
in our lives? You've been planning it forever,
literally forever, and I rejoice in that, and I praise you.
Oh, God, bring that holiness to pass.
Thank you, Lord. Show us what's next. Open the doors.
Open our eyes that we might see what is next and how to move forward.
And if you'll show us that, we'll walk in it. We'll follow it.
We'll pursue that holiness for all the days of our life.
We pray that you do these things for us, demonstrate it for us, and we will
achieve that which you have always planned eternally for us to be.
In Jesus' name.
Now, I'd encourage you to continue to pray. Seek the Lord with your own words.
Maybe you have particular things you need to ask Him about.
Maybe there's particular ways in which you need to pray and remind yourself
of the glory of His plan that He's always intended to bring about in
your life. Let's keep praying.